what are the biggest problems of
uh the job of truck driver currently
yeah the the job the problems with the
job and the labor market right but let's
um let's start with the job which is you
know again
just so much time that's that's not
compensated directly for the amount of
time
um and that's just psychologically and
this was a big part of what i you know
sort of i studied and for the first book
was
you know that conception of like what's
my time worth
right and like
what truck drivers love is
oftentimes is that tangible
uh outcome-based compensation so they
say you know what you know honest days
work i work hard i get paid for what i
do i drive 500 miles today that's what
i'm gonna get paid for
and then you get to that dock and they
tell you sorry the load is not ready
go sit over there and you stew
and that weight can break you
psychologically because your
your uh your time
every second becomes more worthless yeah
or worth less
yeah and again the the industry's gonna
say
for instance
okay well you know they've got skin in
the game right that argument about sort
of compensation based on sort of output
right um but that's a holdover from when
you couldn't observe truckers now they
all have you know satellite-linked
computers in the trucks that tell these
large companies
this driver was you know at this gps
location for four and a half hours right
so if you wanted to compensate them for
that time directly and the trucker can't
control what's happening on that
customer location you know they're
waiting for that you know firm that
customer to tell them hey pull in there
um
and so
what it becomes is just a way to shift
the inefficiencies and the cost of that
onto that onto that driver
now it's competitive for customers so if
you're walmart you might have your
choice of a dozen different
trucking companies that could move your
stuff
and if one of them tells you hey you're
not moving our trucks in and out of your
docks fast enough we're going to charge
you for how long our truck is sitting on
your lot if you're walmart you're going
to say i'll go see what the other guy
says right
and so companies are going to allow that
customer to essentially waste that
driver's time
you know in order to to keep that
business
can you try to describe the economics
the labor market of the situation you
mentioned freight and railroad
what is the
sort of the dynamic
uh financials the economics of this that
allow for
such uh
low
uh
low salaries to be paid to truckers like
what what's the competition what's the
alternative to uh
transporting goods via trucks like what
seems to be broken here from an
economics perspective yeah so it's uh
well nothing it's it's it's a perfect
market
okay right i mean so for economists this
is how it should work right um but the
inefficiencies like you said sorry to
interrupt are pushed to the truck driver
doesn't that like spiral doesn't that
lead to a poor performance on the part
of the truck driver and just like make
the whole thing more and more
inefficient
and it and it results in lower payment
to the truck driver and so on it just
feels like
in capitalism
you should have a competing solution
in terms of uh truck drivers like
another company that provides
transportation via trucks that are that
creates a much better experience for
truck drivers making them more efficient
all those kinds of things
or how is the competition being
suppressed here yeah so it is the
competition is based on who's cheaper um
and this is this is the cheapest way to
move the freight now you know they're
externalities right i mean this so this
is the
explanation that i think is is obvious
for this right there there are lots of
um
there are lots of costs that you know
whether it's that driver's time whether
it's the you know um time without their
family whether it's the you know
the fact that they drive through
congestion and and spew lots of diesel
particulates into
cities where kids have asthma and make
our commutes longer rather than more
efficiently use their time by sort of
routing them around
congestion and rush hour and things like
that
it this is the cheapest way to
to move freight um and so it's it's the
most competitive a big part of this is
public subsidy
of training so when those workers are
not paying for
um the training you and i often are
so if you you know lose your job because
of um you know foreign trade or
um you're you're a veteran using your gi
benefits um you may very well be offered
you know training
publicly subsidized training to become a
truck driver and so all these are
externalities that you know the the
companies don't have to pay for and so
this makes it the most profitable way to
move freight
so trucks is way cheaper than uh trains
well over the long so one of the big
stories for these for these companies is
that the average length of haul um which
which becomes very important for
self-driving trucks the average length
of haul has been steadily declining
um over the last 15 years or so you know
this industry collected data from sort
of the you know the big firms that
report it but you know roughly been cut
in half from typically about a thousand
miles to under 500.
and under 500 is
what a driver can move in a day right so
you can get
loaded
drive and unload you know around 400
miles or something like that
you